we are asked what number should replace
the a and B in the multiplication table
so let's just make sure we can read this
multiplication table the way you think
about it is if you wanted to figure out
it goes up to six so if you want to
figure out what any number up to six
times another number up to six is this
table will tell you so for example if
you wanted to figure out what three
times two is you say okay three let me
take the row that has this three in it
and then the column for the two so three
times two so if you're in this row three
the three row and you're in the two
column three times two is going to be
six here or another you can go the other
way around this 12 this means that three
times four is 12 or right over here this
25 notice this is the same row as this
five and the same column as that five so
it's saying that five times five is 25
and so you notice that if you're going
to any row you're counting by that
number and if you go into any number if
you go into any column you're also
counting by that number so for example
in this twos column right over here you
go you're counting by two is two four
six eight in this five column you're
counting by fives five 10 15 20 and that
makes sense because 5 times 1 is 5 5
times 2 is 10 5 times 3 is 15 5 times 4
is 20 and the same thing is happening as
you go up a row 2 4 6 8 because 2 times
1 is 2 2 times 4 is 4 on and on and on
you're counting by twos here you're
counting by 6 is 6 times 1 is 6 6 times
2 is 12 6 times 3 is 18 6 times 4 is 24
so hopefully now we understand the
multiplication table and it is actually
pretty pretty cool to just keep looking
at it and thinking about how it works
but let's answer their question what
would a and B be well we have this a
right over here so one way to think
about it it needs to be whatever 4 times
4 is and you might know that 4 times 4
is 16 4 times 4 is 16 or another way is
you could just go down this column and
count by fours 4 8 12 and then you add 4
again 12
four is sixteen now let's figure out
what B is and actually let's do it that
way if you were to B is in this column
so we can count by threes three six nine
add 3 to that you get to 12 so B could
be 12 or you could go it from the row
you go for 8 add 4 to that you get 12
and that makes sense because this where
B is that should be whatever 4 times 3
is because 4 times 3 is 12 then they say
complete the inner complete the
inequalities with the greater than less
than or equal symbol so a is greater
than B greater than and I always
remember the greater than symbol because
it is opened to the number on the left
the number on the left is greater then
it's open to the larger number a is
greater than B because 4 times 4 is
going to be greater than 4 times 3 is
greater than 4 times 3 all right 4 times
4 is greater than 4 times 3 it makes
sense you have I guess if you view 4
times 4 is 4 4 is in few 4 times 3 is 3
4 is you have more fours here so
hopefully that makes sense let's do
let's do a couple more of these so now
what number should replace a and B in
the multiplication table so same idea so
a should be whatever 4 times 5 is so it
should be 20 or you could look at
whatever row or column it's in if you
look at its column 5 10 15 20 now let's
do the same thing for B B should be
whatever 5 times 4 is well that's going
to be 20 as well that's going to be 20
and you could say well like a is going
to be 4 times 5 which is 20 and B is
going to be 5 times 4 which is 20 so
either way you look at they're the same
so complete the inequalities well a is
equal to B because 4 times 5 is the same
thing as 5 times 4 doesn't matter what
order you multiply them in let's do one
more of these I think you're getting the
sense of it so what is a so we see it's
in it's it's where it's located it's in
this row for this 2 and the column for
the 6 so it needs to be whatever 2
times six is which is twelve and you
could count by sixes six twelve or you
can count by two is two four six eight
ten twelve to get to a now B this is
going to be whatever six times two is
well that's going to be twelve again be
twelve again and so it's just like the
last one we sell a is going to be equal
to B because two times six is equal to
six times two let's do one more this is
this is actually a lot of fun all right
so a could is whatever four times one is
which we know is going to be four B is
going to be whatever one times four is
which is also going to be 4 and I think
you see a pattern here
AE equals B because 4 times 1 is the
same thing as 1 times 4